let's say that i love to collect marbles
and i love to do it so much that sooner
or later my my entire room filled with
marbles and it's just this huge mess and
when i look at them i have no idea how
many marbles i've collected so i have
all of these marbles so i decided to do
a little bit of organization so i could
draw what my room looks like initially
but it would fill the screen with
marbles so what i say is well you know
maybe i could get organized by i could
take 10 marbles at a time so let's say
you know let me draw 10 marbles 1
two three four
five six seven eight
nine ten and i put them in in cans in
marble cans that exactly fit ten marbles
right so let's say
that they exactly fit 10 marbles so let
me draw let me see how well i could draw
a marble can
actually let me draw my marble cannon
in purple
so that's my marble can and let's say
that it fits exactly
ten marbles
of course i could draw my
my ten one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten so it had exactly ten
marbles in it and i called this a 10 can
so this is not a tin can a 10 can so
this is 110
110.
so good enough at least this you know i
put all my marbles in in 10 cans i might
have a few left over um less than ten
because obviously i had ten i would put
it into a ten can um but i put them all
in ten cans but then i i
i'm such an ambitious marble collector
that i've collected so many tin cans
that i can't even see how many i've i've
collected my room is now full of these
so i say well why don't i put these
ten cans uh or the marbles in them into
an even bigger can so i take essentially
ten of these ten cans and i just decided
to do ten just because
that happens to be the base system that
we live in
and i don't want to confuse you with
base systems but take my word for it
so i take 10 of these let me see if i
can draw them
that's 1
2
three
apologize if i'm boring you
four
five halfway there
six
seven eight
nine
ten
as you can see my drawing gets
worse as i
as i get tired so these are ten cans
each one is one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten marbles and i'm not
gonna do it for all of them but you can
imagine they're all they all have
exactly ten marbles
so i take a bunch of let me let me just
finish this so you know that there are
ten marbles in each of the ten cans
not tin cans 10 cans
is there 10 cans
that's
i don't want you to think that they're
only six i want to
give the impression that there are 10 in
each one
and i'll take these 10
and i'll put them into what i call 100
can and that makes sense right because
if i have
10 cans with each of them holding 10
marbles
then i have 100 marbles right 10 cans
times 10 marbles per can
so i take 10 cans at a time
and i put them into these bigger cans
which i've recently purchased and i
called these hundred cans so a hundred
can looks like that and it's nice
because it's doesn't get confused with
the word ten
so my hundred can looks something like
that
this hasn't been drawn to scale a
hundred can would be roughly ten times
the size of a tin can
i could actually draw the ten cans in
here but instead i just pour all the
marbles in so i have just
i could say a ton of marbles we know
exactly how many marbles are in a
hundred can there are a hundred marbles
in them
right that makes sense 10 10 cans
take all the marbles in them and you get
100 can so this is 100
100.
fair enough i'm i now look at my room
and there seems to be some reasonable
organization going on
but once again i am such a good marble
collector that even the hundred cans of
dude i have i have
i have tons of hundred cans looking
around the room and and once again i can
just look at my room and i don't know
how many marbles i have so i start
putting those together and i create
something called a thousand can so i
take 10
100 cans let me see if i can draw them
so it's not going to be scale so this is
100 this big thing that i drew in brown
i'm going to do the same thing that's
one
that's two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
9
10. and these are 100k so you know this
looks small but i just drew it that way
so i could fit it but you know if i had
to draw that scale the marbles are all
you know it's really full of marbles you
almost can't see each individual marble
because i drew it so small now
this is just full of marbles
each of these cans has a hundred marbles
this this big thing is the same thing as
this thing right here each of these have
a hundred marbles
a hundred marbles
so if i were to pour
all of these marbles into a
humungous can a humongous can this is
massive and i'm not my drawing won't do
it justice because i have to fit it on
the screen but it's going to be
it's going to be 10 times the volume of
this can or ten times the size of that
hundred can i mean you can imagine if
that's the size of a hundred can there's
gonna be a ten can right
so and it's going to be full of marbles
i mean the marbles are so small to be
like little dots right they're just
gonna fill up the whole thing you can't
even at this scale it'd be hard to even
see how many marbles you have in there
and that is a thousand can
let me do it in green so this is a 1 000
can
one thousand can
and just you have a sense of scale if
this is the size of a thousand let me
show you how i so all of these these ten
hundreds right
and and hopefully you know that if i
have a hundred times ten i get a
thousand and if you didn't i you know it
now
so if i get 10 of these 100 cans and i
pour all the marbles into this thousand
i can pour all of them into this big can
and i have a thousand marbles in this
can and this is a sense of scale if this
is the size of a ten of a thousand can
so i did a thousand can in green
if this is then this would be the size
of a hundred can and then a ten can
would look something like this a ten can
would be like tiny it would be like
it would be like that size
just so you have a sense of scale that
thing would look like that if if this
big thousand can is this size and then
an individual marble would be like a
little dot it would be like that i mean
i don't know like that i don't know if
you can even see it that's how small it
would be
so fair enough now not only am i a
marble collector but i've i have um
filed for patents on these various cans
and i won't go into what a patent is but
maybe you can ask someone but i have
invented these cans for helping me
organize my situation so let's let's
let's take a couple of situations that i
encounter as a marble collector and
let's see if these cans are
actually helping me keep track of things
so let's say i just you know i have a i
have uh a big sack of marbles that i i
collected today and i you know i want to
i don't want to sit and you know it must
be thousands and thousands of marbles so
but i don't want to sit and count them i
have i have better things to do than
count i could be collecting marbles
so what do i do
let's remember a thousand is green 100
is brown 10 is this purplish color
invert colors okay so let's say that
after filling up uh
i have this sack of marbles let me draw
the sack
and i'll do it in a different color it's
a red sack of marbles
so you know it's a sack so you know it's
not
and it's full of marbles
so you know it's just tons of marbles
in this sack too many to count too many
for me to count
so what i do is i pour them into some of
the cans i have right
so let's say i start pouring into the
cans
and i
i fill
um
what were the colors
let's say that i fill
three of the hundred marbles
so let's say you know this is
this is a hundred can
here's another hundred can
and here's another hundred can
and i fill them up as as much as i can
right i fill them to the brim with
marbles so this is what i start with and
i i pour as many as i can into this one
i was like oh i still have a ton more
and i pour as many as i can to this one
i fill it up i pour as many as i can
into this one
right and let's say that i even had
another 100 can
and then let's say let's say that i you
know i tried to fill a 400 can
but i wasn't able to fill it up all the
way
let's say it only filled roughly halfway
so i'm like well i can't use a hundred
can because i still don't know how many
marbles are in this one so first of all
what's our sense of how many marbles we
have so far i filled up
three
marble 300 marble clams let me write
that down so this is
100
100 can
100
this is 100
this is one hundred
and this is a hundred can
so you know these went into
those this is a hundred can
so let's just think about it a couple of
different ways i have 300 cans here so
this has got to be 300 marbles
and then i had another 100 can here that
i couldn't fully fill up if i filled it
up exactly to the brim then i would have
had 400 cans right so this is going to
be so i essentially have 300 marbles and
i have some extra
so how do i count the extra well i can
fill them into other cans that i might
have and so you can imagine i can use a
tan can so let's start filling that into
ten cans
so let's say i take this this kind of
surplus marbles
and i start filling 10 cans
so let's say i fill four 10 cans to the
brim
i fill four of them
to the brim
four of them to the brim let me so
you know each of them have 10 in them
i fill four of them into the brim so i
took those that whatever number i had
here it almost filled up my it may be
halfway filled up my hundred can i
filled four to the brim and then i had
another 10 can
right here
oh that's a slightly different color but
i think you get the idea
and then i had another tin can
that
i tried to fill it to the brim
but it was a little bit short it didn't
get completely full right
so first of all let's just get a sense
of how many marbles we have well we had
300 that we originally filled and then
we had these that we couldn't fill a can
with so we dumped them into some ten
cans so this was
this was one ten
this was another ten
and this was another ten
and this was another ten
and this was something less than 10. so
we have 300 here right 3 times 100. we
have 410 cans what's 4 times 10. well
that's 40 right let me do that that's
40. what was this this was 300 right 3
times 100 cans
and then we have something a little bit
extra this 40 doesn't count this because
we don't want to count cans that aren't
full because we don't know exactly how
many marbles are in that so what i do is
i say well i don't have anything smaller
than 10 can i'm just going to let those
marbles sit out in the open so i pour
those marbles out
and i count those separately because i
have time to count less than ten marbles
and i have exactly one two three
four five six seven eight
nine marbles there and that's just basic
counting i have nine marbles
so my question to you is how many total
marbles do i have
well i have three hundred cans full of
marbles which represents three hundred
marbles i have four ten cans of marbles
that represent
forty marbles right four times ten
and then i couldn't fill up that last
ten can so i dumped them all out and i
counted exactly nine marbles so i have
300 plus 40 plus 9. let me write that
down so 300 well i already wrote them
down but i could write them down a
different way i could write them out as
300
plus
what did i what color did i use i used
purple
300 plus forty
plus nine
and i'll do the plus in a neutral color
plus
nine
so how many marbles do i have when this
is where um well you might you probably
are already exposed to this on some
level well there's a simple way of
writing 300 plus 40 plus 9.
we use what we call you know number
places
we could say well
this is equal to let me
the number
300
and
40
9
and the way we know that this is 349 is
because we know that this what we call
place
and the place
we if you if you kind of say that well
you know this the nine is the ones place
the nine tells us exactly you know
after after we filled our hundreds
buckets or our cans our tens cans how
many did we have left over that's this
place ex the one all the way to the
right and before we learn about decimals
but in this situation it's the one all
the way to the right this is the ones
let me write that
this is the ones place and it
essentially tells us how many individual
marbles we have
the second one if we go to the left this
is called the tens place
and it tells you it's essentially
telling us how many ten cans we have or
how many cans of ten and then this the
third one to the left that's the
hundreds place
hundreds
and all it's telling us is it's
essentially just counting the hundred
the hund the number of hundred cans we
have so a very easy way you know and the
whole reason why i did this in the
beginning i take my my sack of marbles i
fill up three of the hundred
cans then i had some left over that i
filled up four of the ten cans and then
i had nine left over before filling up
another can so i immediately know that i
have
three hundred cans
four ten cans
and nine single marbles left over i
immediately know i have 349
marbles
hopefully i haven't confused you and i
have inspired you to collect marbles i
will see you in the next video where
i'll do more
more problems involving our our marble
cans and place notation see you soon